so last night on tucker tony babalinsky
a former business associate of hunter
biden
made some big claims about joe biden's
involvement and hunter's
shady dealings sitting with jim biden
and hunter biden
and joe came through the lobby with his
security
the hunter introduced me as uh this is
tony dad
the individual i told you about that's
helping us with the business that we're
working on
and the chinese the former vice
president has said he had no
knowledge whatsoever of his son's
business dealings and was not involved
in them yeah that's a blatant lie
i know joe decided not to run in 2016
but what if he ran in the future
aren't they taking political risk or
headline risk
and i remember looking at jim biden and
saying how are you guys getting away
with this like or aren't you concerned
and he sort of looked at me and he
laughed a little bit and said
plausible deniability
plausible deniability it's the name of
my yacht
now with six days left in this campaign
the chattering chuckle buckets will say
this story isn't gonna move the needle
maybe but that's only if you're looking
at this politically the big picture
we live in a world where the news
depends on who the media wishes to
protect or harm
if it weren't a biden but a pence this
would flood the airwaves
we would have to sedate the entire cnn
anchor team with elephant tranquilizers
but today most journalists are democrats
and are forewarned if you report on this
story
you'll be helping trump get reelected so
don't touch this story with a 10-foot
poll
or a hunter's case a 10-foot stripper
pole it's the same thing with riots
any honest reporting helps trump so
don't do it
but if this story had implicated trump
can you imagine
well you don't have to this guy
colemnate keeps turning up again and
again
constantine columnist constantine
kalanick and constantine kalimnik
constantine preliminary he's still
russian military intelligence giant
aluminum smelters
he started sleeping at his smelters
sabotage in his smelters came to his
smelters
very brutal start right sleeping in the
smelters tick tick tick tick tick
boom started ticking again tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick
four hours later boom boom you're
stressing me out
he starts tick tick ticking again
whoever smelled it ah those were the
days when unsustained
unsubstantiated rumors created nightly
comic masterpieces
yet we aren't even acting close to this
nuts over hunter
and we have tapes in the words and the
witnesses yet we see a media blackout
all agreeing
to take a dive as reporters bring up
hunter it's like breaking wind in the
world's tiniest elevator
how dare you screams the press well we
learned how to live with lies from the
best
or worst that's you the left-wing media
our trust
in you is gone and you're despised by
all so while you ignore hunter the rest
of america
ignores you
so dana we were talking about this i
think it was i was talking about it with
you
anyway we were talking about like if
this had been somebody else there would
been
like reams of reporters or or teams of
reporters
tmz would be parked outside his house
but there's none of that
well what's interesting is that because
there isn't any of that that's why you
see
fox news and having some of the biggest
ratings
of its entire existence and i
think that voters are smart enough to
figure things out they can read a story
they can decide and i don't actually
think that
voters are just are choosing to vote on
corruption right i mean i just i just
don't think that is i think that
the bigger picture is so much more
important the way that the president
frames it right he says go with me you
get the american dream go with him you
get the socialist nightmare
but these issues of character if that's
what we're worried about right so if
that's what they say they're concerned
about
this would be one of those issues and i
think that the media has
made this decision is it's not like greg
back in the old days where there was
just a newspaper so you had limited
space
there is unlimited space to cover this
story on a thing called
the internet that al gore invented you
might have heard of it yes
that doesn't that doesn't that doesn't
take up
space you're able to cover lots of
different things in fact
the new york times today has a whole
feature
on can you tell if somebody is a biden
voter or a trump voter by
looking inside their refrigerator so
there's plenty of space
and plenty of opportunity to cover lots
of different aspects of this
well kennedy if you look into the
refrigerator of a libertarian
what do you find a drifter you find
uh bags of weed and human heads uh no of
course not but you also
you don't find uh 18 a quart ice cream
like you do in nancy pelosi's fridge
i'll tell you that much
this actually yes this reminds me of the
harvey weinstein case because there were
so many whispers
and you mentioned fore knowledge which i
think is really important and so many
people knew
what harvey weinstein was doing but very
few people were brave enough to actually
stand up to him
seth macfarlane did when he hosted the
oscars and so did brad pitt when he was
dating gwyneth paltrow he went up to
harvey weinstein reportedly
and threatened him because of something
that harvey weinstein had said to his
then
girlfriend and there are a few lonely
voices who
are covering this and you know what the
hope is
that hunter biden is just a really yucky
person who has done
some classless things and made
questionable choices
and they hope that that is how it's
contained and this is what i warned
about during the impeachment is that
if you lower the bar so much and if you
create
uh this simple threshold for impeachment
then you
have to apply that universally to both
sides
and if tony bobolinsky is saying that
hunter biden knew about
all of this if any of that is minutely
proven
and joe biden took a dime from any of
that then
why wouldn't you if you're using the
same
threshold in the same standard why would
you not impeach
joe biden and that's why you have to be
careful with these things because at
some point
the entire script is going to very
inconveniently flip
yes impeachment is contagious juan why
don't
why don't the republicans start a
preemptive impeachment
on joe biden in case he wins they could
actually start it tomorrow
what do you think well yeah i i think i
think that's a great show that's a great
show we should put that one up there as
an idea
i'm sure we get prime time i mean you
know for me the bottom line
the bottom line here is conspiracy
theories are very entertaining
including a possible impeachment hearing
before the man's elected
uh but but i would say how credible
is this guy i mean i just don't know
what i do know
is that you know the trump camp took him
and all their documents to a house in
virginia and had a
wall street journal reporter somebody
you know at a very credible newspaper
uh our own parent company and that
reporter
then not only listened to him but went
through all the documents and came to a
conclusion
that joe biden did nothing wrong no
money
changed hands to the bidens and so i
think to myself you know
this just is incredible so maybe that's
what the
media focuses on things people care
about like
oh you know we can't go inside
restaurants even though it's getting
cold we can't send our kids to school
that's what people care about and that's
what gets reporting coverage not
wild conspiracy theories
meanwhile it was the impeachment that
kept people from actually
thinking or investigating kovid so i
guess you got to go back to that origin
story
hey jesse uh it didn't matter if the
dossier was legal what happened in the
dossier was legal
or illegal it was about being
compromised so now the media is just
saying oh nothing illegal here as if
that mattered
well first of all juan's claim that the
wall street journal debunked this story
has been debunked juan first of all
second of all
i don't think you even read the wall
street journal article because if you
read the article they did not debunk
this they actually helped
substantiate what they saw my i'd like
peter ducey
to ask you back next question for the
textbook
we'll see if they can do this excuse me
juan let me just give peter some advice
ask the vice president hey mr vice
president you ever met tony
let's see if he can answer that question
because that would settle a lot of
things
you bring up credibility i let's bring
it up who do you believe
do you believe the naval officer that
held a high security clearance that
commanded a nuclear submarine
that has emails and documentation and
voice recordings
who went to the fbi under penalty of
perjury
and said his story or do you believe the
political family
with a history of plagiarism and shady
deal making
who's hidden and ran for the hills since
this broke and three of their business
partners are in prison
the deal is very simple they cooked it
up in 2015 while joe was vp
the chinese communists sent 10 million
dollars to the biden family
5 million of it was an interest-free
loan the other 5 million went to the
holding company
where jim biden the bro held back 10 for
the big guy
so then tony meets with the vp twice on
this
and then when tony wants to put in good
corporate governance
joe biden says no they cut tony out of
the deal
and then they smear him as an a russian
agent when he goes to the fbi but the
best part of the story is this
the communist chinese guy who they were
doing the deal with
he was under fbi surveillance because he
was a spy
and then when he get popped by the sdny
for bribery
hunter biden represents him for a
million dollar fee
and now he's serving three years in jail
so the biden family was doing business
with chinese communist spies who were
under
fbi surveillance boom how's that
for a boom